[Music]
Amigo foreign
Emmanuel
[Music]
[Applause]
it's too hot to do the Sip but then I
was told to do the Sip and Alex Jones
doesn't mind a chair that yesterday and
now I just blew out my own eardrums it's
my own fault it is a little bit I warned
you but the thing that's crazy though is
why would Alex Jones have the headphones
for his own feedback louder because he
only has it in one ear so I guess
I just can't imagine guys sorry I'm
doing a live test today we're going to
be talking about the New York City
subway choke out Bud Light sales and the
pedophile come out yeah it's way that's
way too much in my ears I don't know why
he would do that
uh glad to be with you today look
this is going to be one of those uh one
of those shows where we want to give you
the ins and outs of do You Hear the
squeak readjusted my chick Alex son of a
yeah
we'll do it live okay it's going to the
bird uh
we want to give you the ins and outs
because of course the media is trying to
portray this what happened yesterday in
the New York City subway as a lynching
there's a lot of misinformation out
there on both the left and the right I
think you need to know all the ins and
outs and I also think you need to know
how this affects you we talked about
this not more than two weeks ago where
we did the Dirty Harry and Death Wish
segment where we said look and by the
way let me be clear not to say that this
is vigilantism but we said look you are
going to create more conflict and people
are going to start taking more drastic
measures not that that was necessarily
what took place here but people do feel
the need in the absence of police
officers in the presence of crime that
is irrefutable to defend themselves
protect their loved ones to protect the
helpless you've been told that the
helpless is the man who was choked out
when someone dies and it didn't have to
happen it's always a tragedy to be clear
but you don't need to ruin someone
else's life
based on a lie and that's what we're
talking about today yes there can be a
tragedy a life lost you can mourn it and
you don't have to destroy someone else's
life just like they did with Mike Brown
hands up don't shoot wasn't true Darren
Wilson that man in the realm of police
officers was basically a saint and you
never hear his name again we'll be
talking about that we'll be talking
about Bud Light and their sales those
are down uh and uh Florida has banned uh
pronouns which people think is Extreme
but it's entirely reasonable just ask
South Korea so let me ask you before we
get to that uh first off is your boycott
of Bud Light permanent that's a question
of the day will you ever drink another
one again by the way that includes
Michelob and all and other Bush products
inbev
no thanks and uh how's your city doing
how's your city doing you feel safer and
what do you think about the scenario
there are going to be a lot of points of
discussion today it's going to be kind
of a concept episode number two in
command CEO Gerald hey how are you I am
doing well how are you that was a you
know what I can tell you took a Benadryl
last night
it's not even like 8 and I'm like ah
crap and I'm just dead to the world and
I was like I gotta take a Benadryl the
problem is it doesn't count as an
allergy attack if it's from the sulfites
of the bottles of wine that you consumed
a bottle it's a self-induced allergy
attack
because he's too sexy for his everything
oh you can go see him at the comedy zone
in Port Charlotte Florida this weekend
May 5th and 6th and all of his other
dates at briancallen.com May 5th and 6th
Brian Callan how are you sir I'm just a
man I don't need bread guys and that's
the most important thing if you're
wondering why my skin is so tight on my
face it's because I take no prisoners
okay well my belly's tight my arms are
heavy does everyone just decide that the
hello on this show like Alex Jones and
Brent have a meeting behind my back
where it's like they're just going to go
on I'm just punking you right now I'm
just saying I'm just stating the obvious
people are going what's going on with
that guy does he do Sports all day it's
like that's what I'm saying right now
the answer is yes okay I see I see it
and I think you recover all day because
that's what's important thank you thank
you active recovery
one blood tear yes and by the way to
everyone out there if you signed up
prior to May to any mainstream
conservative streaming service that
exists right we know that you may have
signed up for Mud Club we cannot reach
you we know that some of you didn't get
mugs just send your proof to
we will give you three months free if
you're a member of anywhere else you
don't have to cancel anything anyone
else just
for free within that last year by the
way in about a week we'll be sending out
emails with the code for you guys to be
able to get on at the very least so yeah
start to see it roll out so if it takes
about five days yeah you need to check
your inbox you have to I know some
sometimes we're like uh what do I have I
have to click ah it burns just check
your inbox I mean you get the code for
three months free come on all right
before we go on to everything else uh
here's a girl who uh is talking about
this is the state of modern
relationships see if you can spot uh one
of the problems
guess who made in
why does she whisper the part that's
probably super transparent with you it's
almost a hundred dollars in my first 24
hours so when I posted that I started
one yesterday like the number one
question I got was you still with your
man
I am still happily with my boyfriend he
is super supportive of what I'm doing
and you know
it's a business no no we don't no we
don't know if it ain't easy we don't
right unless he's unless he's a pimp yes
and he wants to play video games and
make her work all day yeah
100 now I can take that vacation and by
that stand under 40 Grand a year maybe
my only fans pimp can now get that iron
glove a hundred dollars a day I can
finally get that operation
almost 100 a day only fans come with a
good 401k and health insurance no yeah
dude gotta hope there's Dental okay I
hope he breaks up with her and says it's
cheaper to pay 8.99 to watch you than
take you
got him well done it's a Dear John only
fan sign up it is I don't know you guys
can comment below would you be okay with
those uh you know only you get it uh all
right by the way it's a live show Monday
through Friday 10 a.m Eastern tomorrow
we have a show of course I don't know
we're doing a scrapyard show or a
theology show it's a it's a mix we got a
lot of stuff in the house we have chat
Thursday it's a we're really going to be
talking about the New York uh the New
York subway choke hold choke up now
they're trying to label it lynching
right they're trying to give it a
hashtag there's so much misinformation
out there and the thing is this this
this
um I've talked about this the fake
victim culture it creates real victims
and sometimes you have someone who can
be a victim though sometimes it's a
victim of circumstance not not
necessarily somebody who's a victim of a
crime at the hands of another person and
you can destroy another life let's try
and be mindful of that as we navigate
the story speaking of destroyed Bud
Light sales
so remember they plumped up the stock
price to say it's not that bad guys Bud
Light sales as far as in-store sales so
we don't even have the actual sales from
what I understand as far as all of like
the actual bars those are down massive
yeah those are down massively but we
can't but it's it's at least 26 yeah in
the final week of April 26 down of
course that's because they decide to
have one of their spokesman Dylan
Mulvaney it turns out they would have
been better off using Dylan roof
Stephen seriously yes somebody has to be
yes back here wait what nothing whoa you
thought it yes seriously but if your
problem would have moved more Bud Light
yeah yeah
you uh Alyssa uh heinershine remember
the Bud Light former VP of marketing she
explained why she thought that using
Dylan Mulvaney was a good choice just to
be clear so we have to give her side of
the story she actually concluded the
interview by telling the reporter to
pull up to the second window and get his
Quarter Pounder meal so that is you know
there it is
you can take your your skill set with
you wow
with you
hello so even the left is acknowledging
that Bud Light is having problems right
New York Times CNN but they're arguing
this because they should have stuck by
Dylan Mulvaney what this is the they
can't admit it like look you're winning
okay I didn't even see that and they're
trying to say no no hold on
[Music]
laughs
to account that it's because Bud Light
is primarily constituted From Bump piss
so that doesn't help it but Dylan
Mulvaney and what's what am I hearing
it's what is that what's going on what
is it hey what is that what is it I
think uh we're filming a new spot
outside Von Valdez yeah they're out
there is
[Music]
I don't know why we got them on contract
and I don't know why he's in Studio B
all right mustache makes me thirsty
that's not a natural reaction I know on
any level I have an issue nothing about
that is healthy are you okay Brian no
it's fine thick did somebody order broom
service hey oh I don't like it all right
sorry just to play on words guys to play
on words no I got that part Dylan
movement that mustache comment is where
I draw them yeah I get it no I
understand uh where I draw the line is
killing people yes right yes uh but
here's the thing there's a difference
between killing people and uh trying to
protect yourself or trying to subdue
somebody uh trying to protect others and
they're being uh involuntary
manslaughter which is what it looks like
is going to be the case with this New
York City subway choke hold the story
everyone is talking about right now and
uh by the way um you can hit the rumble
button hit like if you're watching on
YouTube because they are very effective
in making sure that you see one side not
Rumble YouTube
um so let's just kind of walk through
first uh you've probably heard a lot of
claims right about this uh and and let
me disabuse you as Rhonda Sanders would
say those Notions you probably heard
that this was just a claim for example
homeless man was just murdered another
claim that the crane was race the crime
I was racially motivated uh that the
victim was just a fun-loving Michael
Jackson impersonator who needed food
that there was a white supremacist
Marine who was just going out lynching
people like it's a new sort of Bernie
get situation which by the way is not
even what you understand that to be
there are a lot of myths out there and
again the problem is these well some are
half truths some are outright
distortions and lies will create
an entire second wave of actual victims
you understand that words can destroy
lives and we've seen it happen before
and the truth really does matter here
yeah absolutely and you're not really
seeing the truth right now because
people are running quickly to the
lynching thing that's that's what
they're trying to make this remember the
hands up don't shoot the slogans that
people come up with to kind of promote
this stuff you watch later on today that
maybe will have gained enough traction
it's the New York City subway lynching
that you'll hear that's what you're
going to hear yeah now imagine the fact
that there was a black guy involved in
subdoing of course yeah and we'll get to
that well there are I guess were a lot
of black on black lynchings well it's a
more Niche thing yeah just you know is
there always someone always has to be
different
um
let's go through some of these and
you've been following this point
everyone has this is everywhere right
now I mean CNN right now is saying a
partial verdict reached in the proud
voice editions conspiracy trial I don't
really know that a partial verdict you
guys can let us know if there's an
update there I really want to spend some
time on this so
um if you have children we've always
said this this is not a trigger warning
it's a PG-13 warning yeah we need to be
able to address this accurately
um and the clip we're about to show is
not the clip of the man uh dying just to
be clear but the clip of the lead up of
some of the incident and what was taking
place with the uh the Chokehold so do we
do we need to hit the Fest this is I
guess this is fact this is a fact number
four that you need to know about here
four kind of key facts
warning if you have children please take
them out of the room
all right let's show the clip
[Music]
okay
so there's a lot wrong there here's the
thing this is something people also need
to understand that's a guy what's the
name of the Marine the Marine can
someone give me the name I don't know
that they had the name of the Marine we
don't know that we have the name of the
room we have the name of the man who
died maybe down further if we okay so
um he's holding him incorrectly to be
clear right a Chokehold is not a hold is
not a restraint hold this is not a guy
who is trained in uh performing these
very clearly we did a segment where we
choked out one of our producers here
choked unconscious it takes place in
about three seconds you don't need to
hold it any longer right this is
probably a guy who was trying to
restrain somebody he's not applying it
that's not he's just trying to hold
someone down and get some help because
the police never showed up
just to be clear the response time is
not very good in New York City right now
the crime on subways have reached a
25-year High we're going to go through
all of that but just to be sure someone
may not know how to restrain somebody
before we judge them do you
would you now here's what's important
this uh the 30 year old Jordan Neely
yeah according to my Witnesses barged
onto the train started yelling at Riders
uh this is from the New York Post he
said he had no food he had no drink that
he was tired he doesn't care if he goes
to jail he started screaming he took off
his jacket threw it on the ground
apparently also according to New York
Times said he was ready to die and this
24 year old man I guess we don't have
the name of the Marine I don't think
he's been identified yet and that's
probably a good thing that is a very
good thing yeah the police know who he
is so that's fine but not the public he
subdued Neely and put him in a crappy
version of a Chokehold that he held way
too long that's when I knew I had
problems because I I was watching it and
I said two thoughts I went number one he
makes a blonde mustache work weird thing
to say I know it's not healthy but it is
correct also I said you're not grabbing
your own bicep there and that's not a
great that's a guy who's probably
watched the UFC a couple yeah and that's
not fair of me either so these are
larger issues at hand no but here's
here's the important issue is first off
we need better police training and also
just just so keep this in mind when
people say oh Marines can kill you Tim
no no they're not trained in subduing
people just to be clear just because
someone is a marine they don't know how
to subdue someone typically a a
restraint hold a submission hold would
actually make someone uncomfortable in
other words you would put them in some
kind of position where if they tried to
move out of it it would be painful and
so they wouldn't so there's an incentive
to be held there right choco doesn't
hurt Chokehold you go to sleep and it
happens preemptively just to be clear
you need to know this we've talked about
it before you go to sleep preemptively
because your brain is putting itself in
low power mode to protect the lack of
oxygen going to the brain then if you
hold it for another 30 45 seconds a
minute that's when brain damage or death
can occur this is someone who did not
know what they were doing yeah and so
just before that so we showed you just a
snippet of the clip he was laying on top
of the guy right so he had him in that
Chokehold and it was he's not really on
his side like we saw him and the guy was
breathing very easily you could see his
chest going up and down there was not a
lot of panic they were just trying to
hold him to keep his arms from flailing
his feet like there were three people
involved in this thing yeah so that guy
wasn't restricting oxygen to him well we
don't know right I don't know what was
in his system oh we don't know if his
heart stopped because he was taking
drugs before that we know that he
behaved in a very erratic way hold on
that doesn't apparently matter because
we've had other cases after that came up
I can't and we do know this man has a
history of egregious violence I'm sure
he does yeah if you say I'm ready to die
and you throw your jacket off the
alternative is doing nothing and he
pulls out a knife and cuts a bunch of
people and that's true but the violent
behavior that this is an unconfirmed
report so that there are people out
there right now saying hey this guy was
shoving people I was one of these people
uh before getting on that train right so
shoving we don't know yet we don't know
I'm confirmed what we do have confirmed
we'll get to is this criminal record we
do have that confirmed yes of Jordan
Neely he's got he's got an extensive
criminal record yes an extensive
criminal record including felony assault
well there you go uh yeah so we'll get
into that and again that means Grievous
bodily injury along with all kinds of
other violent crimes so this matters
that's because he was hungry right yes
yes exactly unhoused because all homes
here's the thing too by the way I've you
know you know who else has been homeless
at one point kind of myself and by that
I mean I slipped out of my Datsun and
couched her for a few nights and I used
to shower at the 24 Hour Fitness where I
could get a one month pass and then I
got a one month pass to Gold it's a
private dancing I milked the system man
that's what you did you get a gym free
pass you sleep out of your car never
once did I I mean I ate baby food I uh I
would eat uh I would eat scraps at hotel
hotels at one point yes I did wear a wig
I had a feather duster never once did I
consider attacking someone
on the bus line Canadian because I
didn't have home there are lots of
homeless people who don't hurt people
just because that is not an excuse sure
sure it's a tough situation but you know
that there's a gross disservice to other
people out there who find themselves
down and out and they don't choose to
harm their fellow citizens not saying
that happened here but Jordan Neely has
done it for a very very long time a
couple other fast facts and Gerald you
can jump in if I'm missing anything uh
this went on for about 15 minutes yep
from what I understand a freelance
journalist who's on the scene said he
moved his arms but he couldn't Express
anything talking about Neely all he
could do was move his arms none of us
who were there thought he was in danger
of dying none of you we thought he just
passed out or ran out of air the Marine
in question he was uh questioned by the
police was later released that does
matter because the police maybe know
some things that you don't at this point
they could be wrong yeah but trial by
social media is not the same as an
actual court of law or questioning them
by the police who have access to the
entirety of footage yeah that should be
pretty telling and so by the way there
is a little bit more footage there that
shows that the train was stopped the
doors were opened you can hear I don't
know if somebody said like a police
button or pushed the button maybe it's
in a case of emergency if you need
police to that area but you could hear
like on the loudspeakers police respond
to this area please they were just
holding this man and subduing him until
police arrived right which they said
they were holding him for about 15
minutes that makes the response time
abhorrent especially in the subway
system that is known for violent crime
let me ask you this could you in an
enclosed tube handle let's say a
potentially inebriated a potentially
chemically altered man who threw down
his jacket said he was ready to die
would you be able to handle that man for
15 minutes until the cops show up with
full confidence genuine question and by
the way your other alternative would you
just let him run on down the rest of the
subway cars with all the women and
children there and we have a montage
later that is disturbing to see just how
many attacks 20-something year I believe
25 year high in Subway attacks
we said this not long ago we did an
entire segment on Dirty Harry and on
Death Wish and said look
this is this is the exact petri dish for
those anti-heroes that came out in the
late 60s in the early 70s and were there
again and I'm not saying that this is a
vigilante but what I am saying is this
is the precursor to what you will see
you can only lie to people for so long
and tell them that they are not
experiencing violence until they react
to defend themselves and people around
them I'm telling you this is the start
of it
so let's pull it back let's make sure we
go back to Law and Order guys let's make
sure that we are let's make sure that
law-abiding citizens feel safe and
understand that they have the right to
protect themselves in New York City
guess what you have you have no you have
no cash bail right you have no cash bail
you have increased crime and the
inability to protect yourself with the
firearm well what in the hell do you do
all that oh and the cops don't show up
for 15 minutes in the New York subway I
would have thought they'd just hang out
there because they can end their shift
early if they get enough citation the
other thing is that people start like I
have had a lot of experience in New York
on subways and actually have been
involved in altercations myself and one
of the things of course you won well
look do I did I use did I did I use Kung
Fu yes yes was I in the air the whole
time yes that's not important that's
because I'm trained he kept him busy I
kept him busy and when by them I mean a
gang yes but um but for the most part
what you see is most people sit on their
hands yes most people are not trained
most people don't rehearse for this in
their mind most people are terrified
somebody comes on and acting really
erratically and they're big good luck
and it's the rare individual and most of
the time people don't step up and that's
why you see these attacks that go on on
somebody innocent and everybody just
sits around and watches right and people
are terrified of it yes people are
terrified yes so
Workshop keep going yeah I'm sorry this
is not about that he mainly relies in
the uh monkey fist technique yes yes and
and bashful bashful killer yeah I hide
behind my hands yeah it's like drunken
boxing shot and then it's this
I don't know don't give my secrets
that's expensive I love the move where
it's only pay for appetizers now
great here's another fact that you need
to know uh I think this is we are at
number three some key facts number three
the aftermath here uh based on
completely at best inaccurate reporting
or incomplete reporting yeah uh at worst
lies
so The Intercept immediately published a
headline because this is responsible
reading how to not get arrested after
killing someone in public jeez the
nypd's treatment of a white man who
strangled Jordan Neely an unhoused black
man on the subway is not how things
usually usually go down which also
doesn't make sense because you're often
telling us that that's how things always
go down because of something something
systemic racism so it shouldn't surprise
you oh wait that tells you this is out
of the norm this is a situation with
extenuating circumstances and by the way
again we cannot reiterate enough just
because a left wants to turn this into a
race thing it's like Charles Manson
wanting to start a race where one of the
men holding down Neely was black oh but
he wasn't black enough no he wasn't
black apparently I don't know he could
be Bangladeshi I have no idea from that
sale but the point is there's some
pigment can I ask a question when did we
go to unhoused and why
right well wasn't it just homeless in
Portland you're an unhoused camper or an
unhoused neighbor I'm just offended by
the fact that we're going why are we
changing the term is it because
homelessness has a stereotype to it that
you don't have a home yes yes
what are we trying to do here because
the left believes if you just change the
wording it helps it's all better so it's
not even accurate half of them are on
apartment I did it well that's the truth
thank you for being more specific but
the one thing that helps when when a
wretch is on the street and has no uh
access to their mental faculties and
nowhere to live and they're living in
their own filth at least when you change
how you address them to another uh white
person it makes their life yes it does
it does specifically if you say not
without no longer with Co-op that's and
they're like that's better it's better
yeah it's like the Apostle Paul I mean
his things a little less
[Laughter]
ensures that we'll uh lower the suicide
rate yeah exactly also by the way the
journalist who was filming the video
Hispanic so you've got a black man what
assisting and restraining this man a
Hispanic person filming the video you
have a Hispanic person saying no one
actually thought this guy was being uh
killed he just looked like he was being
restrained and then the left already is
trying to frame it not frame it they're
declaring it murder here's another New
York Times uh deceptive subheading okay
it says on Wednesday the medical
examiner's office said the cause of
death was compression on the neck and
ruled it a homicide look look there's a
huge difference between homicide
involuntary there's a huge difference
between homicide and and kill murder and
kill these don't mean the same thing
they don't mean the same thing which by
the way brings us back brings us back
edgy atheists to say if I need a God to
tell me not to Kill ah hold on a second
there are plenty of societies that
actually allow killing and there's no
consequence murder is different why do
we recognize the difference of Muhammad
murder first degree secondary
manslaughter well you may not like it
but because people who created this
country believed in biblical law
believed in natural law and natural
rights and this is maybe why the New
York Times doesn't understand it it's
not just semantics there's a huge
difference between homicide and
accidental death which seems like
it seems most likely is the case we have
to choose my words carefully because we
don't know but why aren't you well and
there's but you're also you have to use
the word objective law too Steve right
yes the objective laws is a super
important thing not subjective law even
though it becomes subjective but for the
most part we start that way yes you know
the idea let me see all the evidence
first yes due process absolutely and
we'll see somebody talk about that here
in just a second but there's also like
when people hear the word homicide they
think murder it's almost the equivalent
in their mind right there is justifiable
homicide oh yes well right so you have
to understand that this is basically I
have a case against you with that nine
times a day I know most of the time this
is basically saying that this guy didn't
this wasn't an accident where he like
fell off a building and died right or
you know negligent homicide is also a
term right where you can kind of say
okay well your negligence contributed to
this this doesn't mean that this person
was murdered and that's not and that's
what they're going for and all of the
evidence we have meaning the people who
were actually there meaning the cops who
reviewed the footage meaning what we
know right now would point to it not
being murdered which again I used to say
don't attribute to malice what you can
attribute to incompetence and with our
next person we're discussing AOC there's
tons of incompetence so I understand the
temptation but I attribute to malice AOC
chimed in Miss googly herself saying
Jordan Neely was murdered period
by the way I hope I hope hey comment
below hit like hope that broad gets
Nick's sandmanned yes I hope that she
gets sued
that is a declaration was murdered if it
is not murder you need to be held liable
because you know what you're supposed to
be representative of the people who
elect you and if a jury of this man's
peers say it's not murder guess what
hope you get fitted for a googly orange
jumpsuit they're gonna put you
next to Kermit the Frog whatever it is
in the lineup so they ID you it's going
to be really really clear just as long
as it's googly eyes and maybe it'll be
you in the craft section at Michael's
and people have to pick you out and say
that's the one that's the one who
defamed me you don't get to call someone
a murderer when you're supposed to be a
representative of the people and
understand due process this is but
Stephen she does clarify you didn't read
the whole
which makes yes yeah that makes it worse
let me let me listen to this you think
I'm mad now I'm just saying maybe she
maybe she'd wanted to clarify further so
let me just hear what she has okay and
by the way I have to read all the typos
because it's hard to write when you're
I'm sorry sir I'm typing my best so
she's not cross-eyed that's a bad AOC
impersonator that is a perfect okay
horses don't have breasts like that
that's all right I don't know I'm not an
equine therapist Jordan nearly was
murdered okay she said but BC beginning
because but because Jordan was houseless
so now we have a neutron but because
Jordan was houseless and crying for food
in a time when the city is Raising rents
and stripping services to militarize
itself while many in power demonize the
poor the murderer gets protected with
passive headlines plus no charges it's
disgusting let me correct everything
that she just said okay because in the
city that is Raising rents because in a
city that is having people flee in
record numbers and is stripping services
to militarize itself while many in power
genomics demonize support what you
really mean is defunding the police and
cash bail and a gutless mayor and Rising
crime the murderer gets protected with
passive headlines and no charges what
you really mean is someone finally
decided that he had enough and they're
going to defend themselves and the most
vulnerable amongst them you you
okay it's disgusting I agree on that
part now mayor Eric Adams called out
aoc's tweet which kind of surprised me
which means he knows something that you
don't let's show the turtles Club
himself there's also this from
Alexandria ocasio-cortez the democratic
congresswoman she said Jordan Neely was
murdered what is your response to what
they're saying here well both the
Congress congresswoman and uh the
controller the controller is a Citywide
leader and I don't think that's very
responsible at the time where we're
still investigating the situation let's
let the D.A conduct his investigation
with the law enforcement officials to
really interfere with that is not the
right thing to do and I'm going to be
responsible and allow them to do their
job and allow them to determine exactly
what happened here that means he had a
conversation with the D.A who's no doubt
uh significantly left and he's going
this is not the one you wanted
I gotta guarantee that because Eric
Adams Houston was a cop right for a long
time so and then he came out and he's
like uh never made one arrest yeah he
never made one I don't know really just
like to spread rumors very few unlike
the right-wing AOC I'm sorry guys you
really are but yeah if that's the
official way of saying this crazy
that's what he's saying exactly if he's
coming out and saying Ah that's you
notice he didn't really tackle aoc's
comment he went to the Comptroller or
whatever it was the controller saying
well that's a city official that means
we could get sick she's so dumb she's
she's just a terrible person that entire
response could have been wrapped up
dumb nice titties though yeah
I never noticed that's what he was
saying never noticed because that's what
he was saying I look into it that's what
mayor Eric Adams was saying tell
everybody is dumb now status
though
text that was a subject I see I miss
those things yeah I know I'm so good at
reading which we need to make sure it's
available for the hearing impaired
here's a fast fact number two
and I apologize for my anger but I hope
that you also understand Kyle
Rittenhouse we watched it unfold and he
spent a lot of time here so I know what
happens to people's lives when you do
this it's not inconsequential and AOC
knows better for crying out loud she was
complaining that she she was she was she
wasn't even near a pipe bomb that may or
may not have existed and she was talking
about how threatened you have any idea
what's going to happen to this guy you
declare a murderer and turn it into a
race war oh yeah I guarantee you people
right now are trying to dox him yes yeah
but he's going to make a fortunate gun
shows yeah exactly well there's there's
no Chokehold shows yeah there's no
chance way to make a celebrity of them
in Texas yes there are quite a few in
Texas probably owns pit bulls oh and has
access to a well now you're just going
off there's no reason for this so
sorry man but I accept it okay thank you
this is uncomfortable it's how we do
let's go through this who was Jordan
Neely okay so of course the woke left
they're already making uh um they're
like kind of like remember Saint Floyd
they're making him into their newest uh
I guess patron saint of
jerking off on subways they're
venerating him
all right
so you want viewer cops yeah okay that's
about what I expected
Define Justice Just white people dying
to be part of something scary
engage with in a violent way he's
transitioning a lot of us are close to
the homelessness and we are to be
millionaires so to see someone be
treated like that as a homeless person
is scary for people who I mean felons
they're scary people who are who are at
risk of being homeless whose threat is
overdue who's rent is being increased
whose shelter is the next step so it's
really really scary
housing crisis to see homeless people
being murdered
he's a hysterical you're hysterical
victim victim victim victim victim
victim race victim victim race victim
victim race that's all they're doing as
our rent goes up oh okay let me ask you
this remember rent forgiveness you
didn't pay rent for a while was there
mortgage forgiveness and I don't want to
call these people landlords I want to
call them home providers how about that
where the home providers observed what
do you think happens when you don't pay
rent for I don't know how many how many
months or years depending on the state
this is not consequence free and it's
not because you're black okay it's not
because you're a victim white woman or
that your guess is as good as mine with
the necklace there and the Swiffer
haircut I don't know what that was I
don't want to misgender it but it's
weird it doesn't matter what you look
like
the rents do and you didn't pay it and
that person wasn't forgiven now
congresswoman Ayanna Presley and I'm
going to get to the criminal record here
because I think it matters I think it's
important Anna Presley tweeted out the
video that you all know of Neely as
though this is the only relevant portion
as just as happy go lucky Michael
Jackson impersonator which by the way
if you want to if if you want to uh sort
of if you want to uh I guess be imbued
with the the the power of innocence and
and being blameless if you're going to
pick a celebrity like you could have
gone worse with OJ but Michael Jackson
wouldn't be my first choice
[Music]
that's everything
but right now
sorry he asked for money let's do it
let's do it and but in a little bit I
haven't stretched but you know what I
mean well you know what we'll stretch
we'll do it on the Mud Club thing oh
okay yeah yeah and Presley by the way
also included her own diatron I've
watched Tick Tock I know how to do it
yeah I want to hear I want to hear her
uh at least she said black men deserve
to grow old huh well okay okay okay
first off tell that to actuary tables
like in other words black they but like
black men die younger and they die
younger
because of the that you guys
spew yeah big and big big and beautiful
is healthy no it's not there's an
obesity problem right there are heart
problems in the black community you
actually encourage them to be dependent
on government programs EBT wealth the
black life expectancy is less in this
country and you want to say it's food
deserts hey let me ask you this what do
you think by the way food desert is
nowadays you can order anything
online I just order a 12 pack of
sardines for Joe Louis it cost me a
third of the price as it would go into
Sprouts but my point is what do you
think creates food deserts hey you have
to give them free but hold on a
second I own this store hey you have to
let them shoplift really all of it only
if it's under 999 dollars I'm taking my
business elsewhere food desert so black
men deserve to grow old not be lynched
on a Subway because they were having a
mental health crisis I don't know if you
know this I don't really know this
sometimes Mental Health crisis results
in the massacres of people correct yes
yes yeah prolonged mental
because nearly this doesn't mean that
Neely should have died that deserves to
die right that's not what I'm saying but
the idea that it was just a white man
lynching a black man as opposed to a
white man a black man and a Hispanic man
trying to subdue a crazy violent routine
felon
is dishonest Neely had been arrested
take a guess
what would be enough okay
five five ten times what would be enough
for it to be relevant in other words
let's say we're just looking at this
right through like through through your
like children's eyes you know Gloria
Estefan or immigrant whatever the
Christmas song is you want to see
Christmas Through Your Eyes yeah I want
to see felonies Through Your Eyes how
many would be relevant if you're going
okay this guy doesn't know this person
here's this person we end up trying to
subdue and these are the amounts of
felonies or crimes or arrests that would
probably lean toward me being inclined
to believe that he was a threat how many
would be relevant to sort of starting at
five starting I think you got it I mean
right you say five you know what I mean
five right here what do you say five
five is my number five
this is the fourth time I've told you
you better not be here a fifth time
especially yes exactly right three
strikes usually but I counted three but
I'm gonna give you the grace the two
Grace felonies that's it
what if I told you to judge Neely yeah
Michael Jackson himself not himself
and I know people will say well that's
because he's homeless they're making a
crime to be homeless four of
the arrests were for assault and one was
an active warrant
for felony assault in 2021 let me give
you the New York definition of felony
assault it's serious physical injury to
another person my point is would you
immediately jump
to murder if the guy who was trying to
subdue him let's just say he has for the
sake of argument likely no arrests which
would be in line with a lot of people
who are Marines right uh let's say
though that maybe it's 42
compared to uh
one or two in other words who would you
be more inclined to believe was
initiating some kind of incident of
violence in sense of violence 42 arrests
we don't know anything about this guy
what about the cops know because it
probably happened is they went all right
what happened you took this man that's a
trap this is horrible let me see the
footage okay well I'm not quite sure who
was it oh Jordan oh 42 arrests we still
have an active warrant on them you're
free to go sir after 30 and you're the
judge after 30. yeah well is there ever
a conversation where it's like uh you
better not be here at 31st time yes and
then after 40 yeah yeah it's like well
is this this is what you do right after
a while it's like it's what you do right
go out inside you create a problem big
enough problem just for somebody to call
the cops and then you get arrested so
this is what you do yeah all the time
it's your thing it's your thing it's
your careers I'm the recurring Bandit
right so you clearly have something
something is wrong yes you know what
what kind of you know the aside from the
fact that he you know the Michael
Jackson white face is very offensive to
me yeah it is as well but you know what
I'm saying but at the end of the day
depends on the air when do they when
does
it just keep this guy
very least that's the thing this guy had
been in and out of uh shelters right so
he understood where to go to get help if
he really and truly wanted it he
actually went to a shelter that was a
little bit they had more privacy and
they had a little bit more it's a safer
kind of shelter than maybe the normal
one he actually was in that he had been
street performing I think it became less
maybe over 13 15 years people had talked
to him like they understand like this
guy was out there and this guy may not
have always been a problem but at least
42 times he was let me be the liberal
here the liberal would say this is a man
who clearly has a mental health yes
imbalance he's not in control of his own
behavior if you're the liberal it
doesn't mean I want him to die I want
him they get help and be exacted from
and and be in a position where he's
sequestered so he doesn't disrupt
Society do you have a room at your house
available yes that was my first question
look he has been to these you did not
commit to method acting the answer every
time from a liberal is not mine
refugees I agree and I I 100 agree look
you're never going to be able to
completely solve the problem but what
you cannot do is vilify somebody
standing up and saying look not on this
subway car today not me not the woman
that you saw in the background not any
of these other passengers I'm going to
subdue this guy and wait on the cops you
cannot vilify somebody for doing that
now if he intentionally kills him and
was yelling out racial epithets and I
finally got one or something like that
fine we can talk about that that's
different which by the way would not be
the native affectation for New Yorker I
feel like Gerald's been through this in
his mind I finally got one I only got
one Cheryl in his mind racists are like
from Remember The Titans like they're
not acting he's from Tennessee yeah from
the rural Mississippi
what a stereotypical impression of a
racist Gerald
some racists have been to college yeah
he thinks it's uh what New York if you
want to solve this problem if you want a
mental health crisis to be handled
differently more police officers please
more police officers because then the
general public doesn't feel the need
it's hey hey police officer this guy's
threatening everybody this has happened
exactly in our history it's happened
throughout the world but it has happened
exactly in the American history since
the 1960s through today and we talked
about it this is not new and again why
do you only care about the Felon
committing 44 at least arrested 42 times
don't you care at all about hey what
happened to you know believe all women
what happened to stop Asian hate
considering those statistics you you
want to guess that some of those people
who were assaulted just based on
statistical realities likely were Asian
in the city of New York but they're no
longer useful pawns what happened to
stopping sexual assault against women
hey hold on a second I don't know if you
know this someone who's been arrested 42
times including from multiple violent
counts far more likely to rape a woman
than the person Elena Dunham had
regretful sex with and found a condom in
a potted plant just to be clear you want
to protect women I don't know cut it off
at ooh this guy's been violent and this
guy's actually committed all kinds of
crimes including 42 times let's maybe
find a way to protect people who deserve
protecting it's one of the few
legitimate roles of government this is
one thing Libertarians get so wrong and
by the way I'm not talking about
militarization of the police one of the
few legitimate roles of government is to
ensure that people like this don't
continue to interact with people who
have not committed violent crimes it's
one of their few roles which you'd have
to then what I never hear from the
liberal side they never talk about
homelessness being a result of drug
addiction and it's and and uh mental
illness you never hear that well they do
what's going on but then they say it so
but that's the thing so it's a housing
it's a power he was hungry and he had no
house that's what they're talking about
that's not true right that that's this
was a guy who clearly had major mental
health problems yeah exactly like there
are plenty of Housing Solutions most
people don't want to use them just to be
clear and worst case scenario put on a
propeller cap and walk your way into a
Ronald McDonald House I think those are
still around the point is they're easy
to trick now this happened in New York
City
let's look at this the New York City
subway murders between 2020 and 2022
highest in 25 years wow okay at the same
time police resignation resignations
those are up 117 percent
response times are potentially their
worst ever just to be clear let's look
at the recent New York City violence
okay let me give do we have a mountain
Montage or the individual Clips because
we were putting this all together today
and I have a clip here that says we have
a mantra so let me just run through the
list and then let's go to a montage in
case you've forgotten imagine you're in
New York City I want to set the stage
here okay
you're in New York City again all
references available at lottery.com
crime is at its highest in the Subways
25 years police resignation's up 117
crime overall violent crime is
skyrocketing and of course police
response times are extended and you
don't have the right to protect yourself
or carry a gun and criminals are just
basically professional recidivists okay
all right so now let's go through the
list you've been living through this
you've been living through an example of
Christina Lee uh Christina you Lee was
tapped 40 times by an aggressive crazy
man named Killer was on supervised
release you have Michelle yo was killed
when Simon Marshall pushed her on two
subway tracks yeah Frank James that's
about remember the radicalized black
nationalists who opened fire in a Subway
which was uh I think it injured
something like 29.99 people and you have
to take all of us into account all this
crime and you are living through this in
New York City when this man arrested 42
times walks onto your Subway do you
think that maybe in the back of your
mind maybe whether whether you're white
or black like one of the other people or
Hispanic like the man who was filming do
you think that maybe these images might
play a role on your mental state kids
leave the room foreign
he and his wife were also spit at on a
Northbound FAA tracking a 24 year old
passenger who kicks back then the 40
year old swings an umbrella at her with
a keychain in hand which police say
caught the victim's face
as the Northbound end train pulled into
36th Street Station
whatever
taking permutating tour games media
lasers
so you're living through that New York
City
makes me it makes me
violent it makes it makes reasonable
people capable of I wouldn't even say
unreasonable things it makes non-violent
people capable of violent things we'll
talk to you a lot of you young people
who watch most of you writer under the
age of 40 or actually most you're under
the age of 30 who watch yeah or listen
right now you may not know about Bernie
gets we're going to touch on that that's
relevant this happened exactly almost
this scenario in the past of course this
guy didn't actually go out and shoot
anybody but Bernie Getz was assaulted on
the subway
got himself a firearm to protect was
assaulted again and shot people now he
went back for a second round because he
had had enough but the point is this is
the kind of culture that you breed of
course none of this is relevant to
professional racist Al Sharpton because
if racism were to get better he'd be out
of a job
he made sure to jump in on the convo
condemning vigilantism and this is what
he wrote or this is what he said I don't
know I'm reading a quote from National
Action Network how many can you
fit in a room now
foreign
what most people this is the thing when
most people in America heard about
Bernie Getz they said I get it
and since it didn't work then right it
didn't work then when they were trying
to tell you hey you should all hate
Bernie gets because it was a whole soft
on crime right liberal media
retroactively now they try and act as
though
as though Bernie gets was different than
it was kind of like I don't know if you
remember this when Ronald Reagan died
the media was so surprised at the
morning because it didn't work when they
tried to make you hate him when he was
president and then they were surprised
like we're surprised look at everyone
showing up yeah yeah because people
liked him kind of the same situation
with Bertie Getz so Al Sharpton said 30
years ago I thought the Bernie gets case
and we cannot end up back to a place
where vigilantism
vigilantism
vigilantism you know the word I'm trying
to read is tolerable It Wasn't
acceptable then it was and it cannot be
acceptable now oh that's debatable so
funny he brings up Bernie gets how many
people here are familiar with Bernie
gets me yeah that's how old I am yeah it
was covered I was in New York he got so
much support initially so much support
everybody's like yep I've been on the
subway too I get it yep people were so
fed up I know it was a story after Story
this was it was Bernie gets he was
robbed twice okay and then he shot four
teenagers who then threatened him tried
to Rob him again on a Subway in 1984. he
was convicted for possession of an
illegal weapon and he served under a
year in jail right just to be clear
because you're not allowed to have a
firearm basically that's really what it
was but this was a guy what I would like
to see a research team is bring up the
injuries the extent of Bernie gets his
injuries with the first assault it had
taken place this was a guy who ended up
in the hospital I think he couldn't walk
for a significant amount of time I
believe his neck was broken and at a
certain point he just said hey it's not
happening to me again and here's what
interesting
Bernie Getz after this incident how many
other people did he shoot
you think you're getting close to 42
arrests that's one thing that people
don't talk about
there's a huge difference between
someone who is a law-abiding citizen who
is pushed too far versus someone who has
decided that they are going to prey on
law-abiding citizens until they are
pushed too far Bernie gets did not go on
to live the life of a criminal
Bernie gets snapped he ralphied the
Thugs who tried to Rob him again
that's what you're gonna get yeah how
many how many more sub Subway incidences
like that the the the the the train car
not the sandwich shop how many more do
you think have to take place for people
to respond like this wasn't a Bernie get
situation but I'm telling you you're
going to get it
if you haven't already
that's where this is going
hey the good news is there's a solution
there's a solution leftist solution is
you know what keep people in prison yeah
can people in prison if they're if
they're committing violent crimes this
is one thing that I always used to
disagree with and even Libertarians like
the prison industrial complex of course
no one should be arrested for a gram of
weed but 42 I don't give a if it's
a privatized prison I want them locked
up yep my problem with the violence
criminal is a greater problem than that
I have with the prison industrial
complex even though I do I have problems
with both I think our system is more
broken in tolerating violent criminals
preying upon non-violent people and then
condemning people when they respond with
violence and in this case we didn't even
have it we didn't even have a man
respond with proactive violence they're
going to label him a murder anyway a
murder anyway you know what's going to
happen people are going to
see this and the next time they're going
they're going to say themselves well I'm
going to be labeled a murderer anyway
and fan the hammer
there is no why do you mistrust your
institutions why do you think we just
gave you a situation where based on all
credible evidence that we have right now
we don't know it's developing seems like
involuntary manslaughter and certainly
doesn't seem like murder but you have
the media you have the print you have
your elected representatives
already lying to try and Destroy
somebody's life why don't you trust your
institutions well let's just start with
those our elected representatives and
our media and entertainment industry
let's start with those and maybe you
have a reason now yeah Hootie you're
about to bring something in yeah we got
the injuries to Bernie gets after the uh
robbery they threw him through a plate
glass door and onto the ground
permanently injuring his chest and knee
despite his injuries he was able to
assist a police officer in arresting one
of the men there were three of them that
robbed him and they also were only one
of them was only charged with criminal
mischief Mischief
rap scallion stops throwing people
through glass stop Kong oh stop
positively concaving that's almost your
chest
[Music]
I counted the three but I'll give you
two more you know when how long do you
think they reprise the Dirty Harry
series because I'm telling people in
Hollywood there's a strike right now I I
guarantee there are people in Hollywood
right now at the top of the food chain
who are writing who who are seeing an
opening because I remember watching
Harry uh Dirty Harry and those movies I
remember as a kid people clapping in the
movies yes they were like yeah were you
here the day we did this segment
underneath we did a whole segment on
Dirty Harry and on Death Wish and the
reason for them and the result of them
and how there was a disconnect between
people in the media this is exactly this
is the environment right now you have
money somebody's gonna make some money
really quickly let's go to CNN so in the
proud boys case four of the proud boys
have been convicted of seditious
conspiracy I think there were six that
were on trial and New York had been
convicted those are the first ones I
believe yeah
can someone give me the definition of
seditious conspiracy I believe trying to
conspiring to overthrow the governor
okay such a big word okay so you're
being seditious I think that's sedition
you're guilty of not of criminal
mischief but being seditious well I know
what sedition is I'm wondering if
there's a difference between sedition
actual sedition and seditious conspiracy
well he's a little more inspiring to do
sedition yes you're conspiring to do
seditious things I don't know yeah
seditious conspiracy is a crime in
various jurisdictions of conspiring
against Authority or legitimate
legitimacy of the state okay so
overthrowing okay so uh being naughty
read it again booty bring it up
so yeah seditious conspiracy is a crime
in various jurisdictions of conspiring
against the authority or legitimacy
legitimacy of the state conspiring
against the authority or legitimacy all
right right now charge me with seditious
conspiracy of AOC I question the broad's
legitimacy yes when she says this guy's
a murderer seditious conspiracy
illegitimate
I like it illegitimate how about that
that's how broad that definition is
think about that why do you mistrust
your institutions think about broad that
is people act like it people will act
like it's guy folks for crying out loud
it just means that you were trying to
question the legitimacy or or hamper the
Integrity the the perceived legitimacy
AOC is a liar and an illegitimate
representative because she doesn't
respect the laws of her constituents she
claims to represent how about that there
illegitimate seditious conspiracy
everyone else everyone else hey wanna
want to sign your name on that guest
list
I agree yes I agree all right good yes
confirm we're all seditious conspiracy
theorists by the way I suffer from peer
pressure so I don't know I know I know
before the show I got him smoking uh
yeah well I mean because she said I'd be
cool I can be in the gang right guys
okay that's the thing they never tell
kids
they never tell kids cancer is worth it
that smoking makes you look awesome yeah
it does it does smell terrible and die
early but hey James Dean Marlon Brando
Elvis and Sean Penn can't all be wrong
yes they can
did I miss anything you didn't miss
anything all right hopefully this stops
hopefully there's more Law and Order but
hey it's New York what the hell are you
doing it's it's the old American story
get out of it too far yeah the Liberals
take over it's an American Tail come
back American Tail fightful jerks off on
the subway
why am I horning all this
by the way that's something
in New York in a good year in New York
yeah someone spanking it on you on the
subway well that's that's I was about to
say they're like I wish for the good old
days yes exactly like that's best case
scenario I swear I saw that on on a
subway I swear to God in this this rough
rugged construction worker you say it
like you saw it once I mean when I lived
in New York like it was all the time
when I was a crowded Subway is that how
they he just started no one has cars in
New York I'm not saying that I'm saying
you could walk I'm saying why would you
choose that place to you know take care
of this hold on a second Brian hold hold
hold this is not important
I need everyone in this room to shut up
for a very specific reason this is an
important learning experience for Gerald
okay
repeat the question that you just asked
why would you take care of business on
the subway no you said why why would
someone who is we've accepted the
premise serial masturbate on the subway
yeah Gerald asked why would you pick a
crowded car okay we have to start with
his mother
um
you realize as soon as the words left
your message there's no why right
because there are a lot of people on the
subway and that's the point no no it is
the why yes it is
crowded I'm just yes a flasher doesn't
do it into a cornfield Gerald yeah
he likes the attention yes that's almost
what yes that's my presupposition that
somebody who Services themselves in a
crowded area does so because they like
it and they're perverted do they bring
their own potted plant well here's the
thing what do you think does he just
think like he's like why are they doing
incredible Subway I know that that's not
do you think it was just a guy who
couldn't hold it he's like I hope no one
stays in the corner I had to go when you
gotta go you got to go now exactly the
guy there was a construction worker who
who goes he just looks at me goes
he goes you hit anybody with that and
that's gonna this is gonna be your last
day on Earth and the guy didn't know
what it meant and he kind of went well I
put it back in yeah and then I you know
I said everybody's entitled to their own
expression I had to have all my I'd have
all my jackets reupholstered yeah that's
that's just that's just weird it's very
very common my point is it's a little
weird Gerald I will agree with you on
that Brian appreciate that that's just
weird it's a little weird it's odd to me
not to mention criminal yeah yeah it's
criminal I mean riding the subway naked
okay I don't like it but fine well
that's San Francisco that's legal yeah
as long as you're not hard here's the
thing you can use the subway just
telling everybody the rules aren't style
accidents with that I mean those bars
again you can use the subway for good
the metro in Montreal there's a guy who
actually had three flutes one in each
National one in his mouth he did the
entire Star Wars theme song it's
relevant because it's May the fourth May
the fourth be with you finding that ever
elusive mate now that is neat
did you pay him to go away
cleaned up people
he was long before when finally dude
yep with three two nostrils and then one
guy would play the spoons outside of
ogilvies everyone in a party with the
guy who did the Star Wars theme song and
play the spoons while another guy
masturbated is that well that was the
sporting act and that young man's name
was Stephen Crowder he was like the Joey
Bishop of the subway ax it was weird
when he tried to time it to the uh song
especially the crescendo he was just
happy to be there all right
so guys let's get serious seriously
let's get serious uh hopefully this has
been New York sucks yes
yeah all right depends on where you go
so in Florida though while we're talking
about some wins and we'll give you more
updates if the story unfolds I don't
think that there's going to be anything
new and if there is the media is not
going to cover it of course not they've
already destroyed the man's life here's
the thing if everything gets corrected
soon as that Marine his name comes out
his life will never be the same it
doesn't matter the LIE already traveled
believe me yeah we we all know it's
happened a billion times it doesn't
matter so he can't speak on college
campuses and go to New York and certain
things
nowadays I think he's gonna be fine well
he'll be fine but his life will forever
be changed he can eat delay my house
yeah well you don't have a spare room
because they're filled with refugees
that's very true yeah also by the way
you might want to keep it under reps
because I think you're engaged in human
trafficking oh yes that's how the law
might view it I don't know I'm just
protecting Ukrainian women how many
times do I have to tell you that I know
if you're Ukrainian in your 20s and
you're female I'm your guy I understand
what your heart is unfortunately the law
does not look kindly upon protecting
women by locking them in okay I didn't I
have to look at the details padlocks
because I know nudity laws in San
Francisco but I haven't looked up the
Ukrainian women you can't lock almost
any women in a room against their Wills
okay you'll be fine all right well Daddy
because a lot of people watch all right
thank you so Florida's legislature
they just passed a parental rights and
education Bill and uh now of course that
just goes to Governor DeSantis uh desk
for a signature which hopefully he'll
sign obviously
I mean yeah I'll be it'll just be
hilarious just to screw with them to
make a worse bill
I've been vetoed why so that they can
ban all trans people from the state oh
no we're bait and switch so
the bill will prohibit I just wanted to
take a in the Target oh no now I'm
in committee so the bill I'm tired I'm
sorry the bill would prohibit lessons
related to gender sexual orientation
until High School it restricts the use
of gender pronouns and classrooms and
teachers must also teach that biological
gender once referred to as gender is
unchanging so of course Florida they're
Furious about this right here's David
Andrews the woke premiere of Victoria
Australia and this is why I usually
don't care what other countries say
about our country right
[Music]
uh the premiere of Victoria Australia
slamming DeSantis if you want to behind
Floridian
Republican
head over there where your hateful views
might might be worth something they're
worth nothing here we won't stand for
this sort of
ugly Behavior it's appalling and I again
make the point it's not about Free
Speech this is hate speech plain and
simple so right away right that's always
what they're using them it's not free
speech it's hate speech yeah it's simple
Fosters if you want that all right if
you don't if you want to believe that
men men have things like
I bet you probably think that look if
you want to be in a place where kids
parents can force them to keep their
Cooks huh oh place within every type of
venomous spider snake and Shack you
don't know what a photo if you want a
place that isn't a penal quality that
was founded by rapists and murderers
within you as punishment because
everything can do head on over to
[Laughter]
I guess
because I know you don't do it so I
gotta keep it here a man and a woman is
not just a feeling all right I guess
that makes sense well so the current
bill that he had was K through three and
he's basically they're just extending it
to k through eight so high school is
when you can talk about them chopping
off the what cooks yes exactly right
listen Cooks listen if you think that it
mean okay what defines a man is cocking
balls to clean his legs you're wrong
then Australia is just not the place we
can't get get you get your sorry ass out
of the Epic
you go find yourself in Key West can you
go find yourself in Fort Lauderdale
maybe the hellscape that's Miami right
not here this year's Hugh Jackman land
sexiest man on Earth
it's a long flight
nobody wants a good team
that was that that was almost like an
Irish such a long flight yeah it's a
long flight yeah from Ireland sorry yes
on Spirit Airlines okay
Lose Yourself a weave no Qantas for you
huh look like a WNBA game taking place
in the sky
and head on over to oh no maybe maybe
Naples oh but you'd like Naples wouldn't
you with everyone there everyone there
has Cooks
stealing Taps come on over tonight or
Michael Island
it's like the Monty Python sketches
who wants to go for a walk around the
square and like nobody
you're describing heaven to me you're
sending me to Heaven what kind of dad is
just like Hey how
you are screaming you don't get it you
don't get your pornography
[Laughter]
yeah I want to see every bite that's
right
because you know there are people that
that legislature in Australia like huh
yeah is he asking us to go to Florida
all right
is this a request I don't know what
are some fluids safe and I dig that
about you
so here's the thing they act like the
United like Florida is the only place
all right let's give you some more
examples South Korea has now refused to
even allow the gay pride parade in its
main business district they're taking
action against grouping kids or other
countries too but they're scrapping the
gender Ministry they're removing the
term sexual minorities in middle and
high school textbooks uh they're further
attempting to revise sex education this
is a quote by the way you can check the
references uh so that doesn't mention or
cause sexual identity confusion hey I
don't know if you know this hungry
hungry in the EU are in court over a law
meant to keep lgbtq issues out of school
you also have that with Poland just to
be clear hundreds of cities Villages
there's towns have passed completely
lgbt-free resolution I'm not saying that
that is what we should do where you can
of course you can do whatever you want
as an adult what I'm saying is they want
to blame the United States and Florida
for simply saying that you can't
sexualize children that's not to mention
at all you know that and entire section
of the world where it starts raining men
if you speak with a list kids are not
sexual okay kids are dealing with other
things life is more is complicated and
hard enough if you have kids you know
that they're not thinking about
sex it's just not what happens until you
get kids are stupid although I have
noticed with most them too you know
unless you force them too and then
they're kind of like I don't know yeah
they're not sure about it's like yeah
it's like the kid on Magic School Bus
he's like no I knew I should have stayed
home today
yeah
so I knew some guys doing it in sixth
grade just so you know that was that was
yeah that was that was a dark place it
was and then you left me on the terrible
because I ran out of things to say and I
just left dead air and you had to pick
up on it
I said a trap for you you go you go to
Florida right you see it from the Magic
School cook
on the sybian maybe you can you can you
can go over there with that big red
butchering and big red duck we
have normal sized dogs here in Australia
giant spiders and they're not red this
is an Irish City but this it's not
really red it's really more of an Amber
the point is
[Laughter]
so DeSantis by the way is this is an
example of making good in one of his
promises which I'm I'm happy to see
we reject woke ideology
we fight the woke in the legislature we
fight
we find the schools we fight the woke
and the corporations we will never ever
surrender to the woke mob Florida is
where woke goes to die so his wife
should be in pants there I said it his
wife here's the thing his wife is very
pretty oh yeah but here's the problem is
I find she looks very different from
picture to picture so I'm like that's a
pretty woman oh that's his wife she'll
look much younger or she'll have like a
totally different hairstyle there's no
consistency I just know there's a pretty
lady in the picture my problem My worry
is that the right tense that she becomes
not pretty at some point that happens to
all of us Brian whatever not a few not
if you eat well uh and you take the
right supplements briancallen.com for
protein powders um she she is uh she
looks great but the the writers be
careful not to be too calcified in
traditional we lose control of the of
the story then like the left is still
good at creating cool what are you
talking about well hey just looks like
she's the lady and she he's an address
and she's kind of there and her man's
got that tight she's a babe it's a
little it's a little stiff and nerdy you
got to be a little bit more it's a
formal event he had a suit and tight
yeah whatever dude he should have an
open open shirt would you like him to
come out and dance funk I want him in a
bandana there I said all right that's
fine as long as it's the right color I
was gonna say as long as it's not black
red can't be blue just stay neutral yeah
yeah and don't wear yellow because in
the wrong bar that means that you do a
lot of weird stuff so now golden shower
with all the talk of gay propaganda in
school we thought it'd be a good time
[Music]
foreign
you don't know anything I had a very
good I had a good year I um number five
that's the bird term hashtag bird
watchers hashtag no black bird washers
uh sorry well there are no black bird
watches what I'm saying when you say
when you think birdwatch do you think
white person seven Plus One band LGBT
grooming books number five of mice up
men that's one that seems okay I think I
don't know why is it durable first of
all yeah I know I know we gotta tape its
mouth that's the problem is the book is
inaccurate yeah sure it's not a fair
this is what you do because you don't
want the dribble to tell Tales Richard
came out against it although they did
the audio a mice is a mouse's tail is
easy to pull back out on there that's
what we've that's what they tell you at
the local library
what did I say you know I yeah
[Laughter]
number
[Music]
all right number four Gerald Moby's dick
there you go
no not the singer these are the band
grooming books bro
is Don quirodi on there Brian you had
your chance to contribute the writing
I asked a question
is it dirty sanchez Panza
it's a literary joke it's very good I
got it if you that that's only for the
Educators unfortunately most people
didn't get that they didn't read we're
never going to finish absolutely listen
this is we are talking about classical
literature that that man Don Quixote was
was tilting at windmills what he
was known for of course
[Music]
winds it's just so fun for three people
now uh number three
A Farewell to Cox you guys over here
that's the most used word of the show
today I apologize I'm glad I gave a
warning good word though number two
banned lgbtq grooming books in Florida
uh what is it to Brian the Zen of
autoerotic asphyxiation and that's an
instruction manual the problem is it's
in Swedish so I never figured out how to
do it yeah
uh seven plus one not to be found enough
trying to think of something funny to
add to that but all right number one the
pitcher and Catcher in the Rye which is
sad it's sad because it's almost like
they subverted uh something and uh of
the seven Plus One band grooming books
what is it the plus one Gerald Brave New
World that doesn't make sense that's
week seven plus one I guess was I was
Uncle
[Music]
I'm sorry Brian we rudely cut you off no
it's fine I just asked to zip it Uncle
Tom's grabbing was on there
you slept in Brian I mean
they don't get me
you got a pay wall
someone
this is what happens when it's a
stressful day and it's a stressful show
and you have to deal with a topic that
everyone is discussing and it's it's
dishonest and you see someone's life
being destroyed look sometimes we have
to deal with these people behind the
scenes I mean we have conversations with
these people whose lives have been
absolutely shattered and destroyed and
it breaks your heart and we just we
don't need to do that right now we can
get off this train especially if there's
a homeless man servicing himself on it
Brian Callan is going to be where are
you going to be this weekend Port
Charlotte everybody uh just uh I guess
an hour outside of Fort Myers uh that's
in yeah Charlotte Florida yeah let's
make the plug sorry at the vasani
theater
you get three months free just send in
your subscription to free monthly letter
with credit.com uh and then if you're
watching on Rumble right now you click
this button right down here you just
click that one button and it's going to
be a very very uh I see
potentially disappointing chat Thursday
because I think we have a one-track mind
and I'm pretty sure you can guess what
it is and it's not YouTube friendly
Rumble thank you YouTube piss off
[Music]